but today I propose to discuss how the
work to strengthen the
socio-economic potential of crimea
and sevastopol is going on, what tasks
will we have to focus our efforts on in the
near future and in the long
term, I note that since 2015 a
special
program for the socio-economic
development of the peninsula and a number of others have been consistently implemented
events,
yes, of course, the development of the
economy of the peninsula is definitely affected by
Western sanctions that
apply to the banking sector for the
supply of a number of goods, etc., after the
start of
the military operation in Ukraine,
a new package of sanctions followed not yesterday
at a meeting on measures of social
economic support for the subjects of the
federation, I already said that
restrictions imposed against Russia, of course, they
create
many problems, but they create not only problems
, they open up new
opportunities for us, including now there are all
conditions for large
Russian business structures that  well,
frankly, before they were afraid of some kind of
sanctions
sanctions measures, well now they have nothing to
be afraid of now they can safely
come including by the way them and banks to the
peninsula and actively work actively
in the region